Speaker 1: Hey, this is a very strange series
of events. Earlier in the day on Monday,
Jordan Peterson attacked me. He subsequently
went on to call a woman ugly and then announced
he's quitting Twitter because it's all gotten too
out of control. He's told his staff to change his
password and not give him access to it. However,
multiple tweets continued to be posted after that,
presumably by his staff. So let's go
kind of like point by point here. Okay.
So the first thing that happened is that Jordan
Peterson posted about my video criticizing him.
Jordan Peterson recently gave a talk during which
he wept because young people are being told that
there's a climate crisis. And Jordan Peterson
didn't like my video. And he tweeted at me, he
attacked me and he said, quote, I was speaking of
the unacceptable demoralization of young people.
I've seen it all over the world. And this
cynical dismissal is all you can muster.
How utterly pathetic. Pacman, how do you think
endless apocalyptic catastrophizing affects
children? He then went on to send an additional
tweet. He sent a second tweet very quickly
where he said, And congratulations on capturing
an audience motivated to spew so consistently
the corrosive and personal vitriol that makes
up the comments on this video clip. A likely
epitaph for you. Eaten by his own children. So
he's really, really, really not happy with me
now. As a reminder, the video he's referring to
is Jordan Peterson Weeps Over Climate Activism.
And in that video I pointed out we shouldn't be
weeping, that it's upsetting to kids to learn
about what we're doing to the planet. We should
be weeping over the fact that we're destroying
the planet. And Jordan Peterson's perspective
is when you tell children and young people
all of these terrible things that are going
on, it's demoralizing to them. It's horrible.
And he wept. He wept. He wept over it. And my
point was, we have to be honest with people.
And if we're bringing up a new generation, who is,
number one going to deal with the consequences of
climate change and number two, be in a position
hopefully to deal with it? We can't lie to them.
We can't hide from them that this is what's
happening on this planet. And anyway, he didn't
like it. He thinks it's demoralizing to tell
them that. So Jordan Peterson flipping out on me.
Moments later, he went after the physical
appearance of a woman. There is this woman. I
actually haven't been following this story, but
I guess the Sports Illustrated swimsuit issue
this year wanted to feature different body types
and there's a heavier woman who is featured. And
Jordan Peterson, after attacking me on Twitter,
tweeted about this woman. Sorry, not beautiful.
And no amount of a. Authoritarian tolerance is
going to change that. So kind of a weird thing
for Jordan Peterson to be tweeting about. And
then not too long after that, Jordan Peterson
announced that he is indeed leaving Twitter.
It's gotten to be too much for him saying, quote,
So I told my staff to change my password, to keep
me from temptation, and I'm departing once again.
If I have something to say, I'll write an article
or make a video. If the issue is not important
enough to justify that, then perhaps it would be
best to just let it go. A very, very unstable,
incredibly unstable individual. And honestly,
I don't even I mean, listen, Jordan Peterson,
we've talked for a while about how he seems
unwell. We've talked for a while about how
a lot of his followers seem to be sort of like
bamboozled and fall into a cult of personality.
We've said a lot of things about
Jordan Peterson. I'm actually with him.
Significant use of Twitter. Isn't that healthy?
We know that. And for some people in particular,
it's really not healthy. I know people
personally who because of their personalities,
addictive personalities and sort of the endless
need to keep scrolling. I see how corrosive it
is to their mental state, their emotional state
to be on social media. They just shouldn't be on
it. And it really seems like for Jordan Peterson,
it's very bad to be on social media. So I actually
respect him for getting off of Twitter. It's
not clear he's really off because the tweets
keep coming, but I guess it's his staff that
are sending the tweets. But what, a 24 hours
flipping out on me, calling a woman ugly and
then saying it's gotten bad and I'm quitting. So.
We wish him the best. I think it is
better for him not to be on Twitter.